in Britain they call Christmas this
season of Goodwill but you won't find
much bonhomi here Downing Street in 2022
produced pantomime style politics it
might have been funny if the
consequences weren't so serious
Boris Johnson led the way a so-called
partygate dragged on a police
investigation a fine for Johnson
no covid rules were broken and that is
what I have been repeatedly assured and
when photos emerged the story changed it
did not occur to me uh that this might
have been a breach of the rules he lied
frequently and after a while people
didn't take seriously what he said there
is no doubt that the Office of Prime
Minister has been demeaned over over the
past year Boris Johnson became a joke
the Parliamentary party eventually
decided Johnson was a liability many
commentators described it as the Downing
Street soap opera firstly Boris Johnson
simply had to go against his will his
parting words hasta la vista baby I'll
be back then Liz truss she's been
described as playing the leading part in
a psychodrama and then enter stage right
Rishi sunak no friend of as trust and
his nickname
The Invisible Man sunac was dubbed The
Invisible Man because he's been keeping
a low profile with his conservative
party so split support can't be
guaranteed
he only had to look back on the debacle
of the Liz trust Premiership to realize
how quickly back bench MPS can get rid
of their leader
she proposed massive unfunded tax cuts
but the sums didn't add up and she
blamed her friend and Finance Minister
kwesi kuate we need a new approach for a
new era
there was a currency free fall and
ballooning costs of government borrowing
she fired him but it didn't stop An
Almighty financial crash she talked the
talk
I am a fighter and not a quetter had to
walk I have therefore spoken to his
majesty the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party Britain was a laughing stock
worldwide one newspaper here featured a
fresh lettuce webcam would it Outlast
Liz truss yes but with inflation now at
a 41-year high no one's laughing
strikes over pay demands are bound
hitting Public Services they're frequent
and they're causing major disruption the
Royal Mail the trains the National
Health Service hit by paramedics and
nurses walking out
I think this government especially after
we saw what Liz trust done and collapse
public finances I don't think this
government is fit to run a sweet shop
let alone a complex Healthcare System
like the NHS but can Rishi sunak get
away from the Invisible Man image and
set things on course again
he's a bit boring so far but I think he
would be quite happy to be boring and I
think quite a lot of Voters would be
quite relieved to have a boring prime
minister and boring politics for a while
but maybe just maybe this is a time for
managerial problem solving rather than
vision so there could be no humorous
ending to the farce of British politics
in 2022 there's an irony instead the UK
was promised tax cuts by Liz truss
instead it's now weighed down with the
biggest tax burdens since the 1950s
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera London